salut c'est tonton Tarik
tu te souviens
[Musique]
tu as peut-être kiffé tu as peut-être
détesté en tout cas impossible que tu
sois passé à côté
je vais te raconter ce phénomène pour ça
on remonte à 2007
tonton Tarik a dit quelques archives
[Musique]
la tectonique c'est monté très haut et
c'est retombé très vite enfin ça c'est
ce qu'on a voulu nous faire croire
[Musique]
à l'origine l'idée on la doit à deux
Français l'un d'eux s'appelle Alexandre
barousin et lui il sent qu'il y a un
business à se faire au début des années
2000 il squatte les soirées électro que
ce soit à Londres ou aux Pays-Bas il va
monter une soirée qui a lieu dans une
boîte au sud de Paris qui s'appelle le
Métropolis
[Musique]
leur soirée elle s'appelle tectonique
killer d'où le nom tectonique le
principe de cette soirée c'est de mixer
trois genres de musique électronique il
y a la minimale
le Jumpstyle
et le hardstyle
là dessus les clubs vont poser des
mouvements ils vont s'inspirer de
plusieurs danses comme le voguing
ou le Melbourne
mais le mouvement caractéristique de la
tectonique c'est les moulinets avec les
bras je me suis demandé d'où ça vient
cette histoire en fait c'est assez
simple tu vois les bracelets fluo qu'on
te distribue en entrée de boîte quand tu
les mets autour de tes bras et que tu
commences à faire des petits mouvements
et bien ça fait des petits effets sympas
d'ailleurs c'est une création 100% made
in France alors la dernière fois que les
Français avaient inventé une danse
c'était il y a 154 ans exactement
un siècle et demi plus tard donc la
soirée tectonique cartonne au Métropolis
mais si vous n'avez pas l'âge ou la
crête qu'il faut c'est recalage comme on
dit ici deux heures de queue pour rien
et 300 mètres à essayer de faire bonne
figure
ça marche tellement que d'autres boîtes
vont s'y mettre mais là où ça prend de
ouf c'est dans la rue
[Musique]
là la tectonique va passer un cap on la
voit en plein jour en plein Paris il y a
des battles un peu partout que ce soit à
la défense au Trocadéro et surtout à
Châtelet
ça se passe aussi sur internet alors à
l'époque il n'y a pas un staff Twitter
et compagnie non à l'époque il y a deux
choses la première c'est skyblog skyblog
c'est un site de blog inventé par
skyrock en 2002 qui a commencé à bien se
développer en 2005 et deux ans plus tard
en 2007 les blogs les plus populaires se
sont souvent les blogs autour de la
tectonique l'autre truc déterminant dans
l'histoire de la tectonique c'est
YouTube
[Musique]
donc là le gars il s'appelle Djédjé sa
vidéo fait un million de vues ce qui est
complètement ouf pour l'époque et tout
est posé on voit le look les mouvements
le son
et avec cette vidéo la tectonique va
sortir de la région parisienne ça
commence à danser un peu partout en
France
bien sûr comme ça devient un phénomène
la télé commence à en parler voici
maintenant un phénomène la tectonique la
tectonique tectonique un peu en mode
boomer parfois pour danser il faut avoir
le bon rythme et surtout le bon look il
s'agit comme des lémuriens attaqués par
un essai
je vous ai parlé dans des co-fondateurs
de tectoniques il s'appelle Alexandre
barbousin en fait il a déposé le nom de
marque et ça ça lui a permis de lancer
des t-shirts des mitaines des lacets à
l'effigie de la marque tectonique et
tout ce qui est possible de sortir en
produit dérivés en fait ce sont des
danseurs que l'on voit un petit peu
partout ce sont des soirées dans toute
l'Europe c'est une boisson énergétique
pour justement donner la pêche à nos
clients puisque ça rapporte de la thune
et que ça fait danser les jeunes
Français les labels de musique aussi
vont s'y mettre Universal va monter un
groupe je suis sûr que vous le
connaissez c'est mon dothèque bon j'ai
pas les droits pour vous passer leur son
mais j'ai des super collègues chez brut
et je suis sûr qu'ils vont savoir vous
rafraîchir la mémoire non mais souvenirs
[Musique]
le son c'est sympa mais chez Universal
ils ont aussi vous mettez des danseurs
ils ont réussi à sortir Djédjé de son
garage et ils ont recruté d'autres
danseurs hyper populaire dans la
communauté tectonique comme Karmapa et
Lily Asian j'ai retrouvé Lydia
elle m'a montré des images qu'elle avait
filmées à l'époque
ça me fait chaud au cœur je me dis quand
même c'est une très belle période
on discutant avec elle je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait la tectonique avec mon
dothèque avait fait le tour du monde
en Suisse en Belgique
île Maurice Guadeloupe y en a qui sont
partis en Corée et je dors en oublier
sûrement donc voilà ils sont beaux ils
sont jeunes ils ont du succès mais en
fait la tectonique ça commence à saouler
tout le monde le truc est partout c'est
l'overdose médiatique on en a marre de
ce marketing hyper agressif aussi donc
en 2008 et bien c'est fini la tectonique
enfin ça c'est ce qu'on croit
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait la tectonique n'est pas
morte alors déjà on parle plus de
tectoniques ce terme c'est les médias
qu'il avait repris en faisant un peu
l'amalgame entre le mouvement et la
soirée à l'origine la danse
électro donc on la voit plus à la télé
mais elle est archive validée par des
stars de la danse contemporaine en 2009
par exemple c'est blanc Cali une
chorégraphe mondialement connue qui va
s'y attaquer alors elle elle a kiffé la
danse électro donc elle monte un
spectacle qui s'appelle electro qui
donc là les danseurs qu'on voit ils sont
passés pro et en plus on paye pour aller
les voir dans des grandes salles de
spectacles au même moment il y a un
autre élément qui va faire perdurer la
danse électro ça s'appelle le vertify
alors Vertifight c'est une asso qui
organise des battles un peu partout en
France ça a été créé en 2007 et petit à
petit c'est devenu le rendez-vous
incontournable des danseurs en France
puis à l'étranger
j'ai pu échanger avec l'un des
fondateurs du vertify qui s'appelle
human
c'est human human et les gars qui ont
créé ça ils viennent du hip-hop donc ils
ont créé des battles sur le même modèle
que la breakdance
en fait c'était beaucoup de jeunes de
quartier qui faisaient une danse qu'on a
appelé électro ils avaient pas la
structuration des groupes ils avaient
pas les comptes sur la danse il savait
pas danser sur des nappes il savait pas
un moment donné défendre cette culture
qui elle est bas à la base n'était pas
une culture c'était une mode c'était la
mode tectonique d'un coup grâce au
vertify les danseurs savent que leur
look ou leur popularité on s'en fout là
ce qui compte c'est d'être bon de
s'entraîner d'être agressif face à son
adversaire un peu les codes du hip-hop
quoi
la culture hip-hop pensant que la
culture électro c'est des mecs qui
bougeaient les bras mais bon c'était
vite fait quoi ils ont pas compris que
pendant 3 ou 4 ans ces jeunes danseurs
ils sont venus super forts ils sont
venus tellement fort qu'il pouvait se
mettre en face de la culture hip-hop et
même d'ailleurs la culture à l'époque
tout d'un coup elle a calqué ses
mouvements sur la culture électro si un
jour elle a les couilles de recettes
bref grâce aux Vertifight grâce à
blancali et surtout à la persévérance
des danseurs et bien en fait la danse
électro elle est toujours dans le game
aujourd'hui ça pour s'en rendre compte
il suffit de scroller un petit peu sur
Tik Tok
ça danse un peu partout dans le monde
mais la première nation électro ça reste
la France pour en parler j'ai rencontré
deux danseurs l'un de la première heure
tricksy et l'autre qui s'y est mis plus
tard miel aujourd'hui cette danse là
elle est partout que ce soit sur scène
tu peux avoir avec Marion Mottin tu peux
l'avoir avec Christine and the Queen si
tu peux l'avoir dans climax des cases
par Noël mais en fait les gens ils
apprécient et il se rendent même pas
compte que ça vient descendre de
tectoniques en fait c'est dans ça fait
vraiment partie de moi j'ai vraiment
quand je la vois danser ben j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une partie de mon
âme ou de mon ADN qui est dans les
danseurs et je le ressens en fait parce
que il y a un truc que j'ai créé
indirectement dans l'énergie dans les
mouvements et c'est encore ce que je
ressens aujourd'hui tu vois quand je me
mets à danser genre vraiment à percuter
le son ça me transperce il y a des
compagnies il y a des spectacles il y a
des battles d'ailleurs j'ai pu assister
à l'une d'elles il y a pas longtemps
c'était au 6b à Saint- ça ressemble à ça
franchement l'énergie sur place était
assez ouf j'ai pu voir des battles pro
et des battles amateurs il y avait des
gars qui dansent depuis le début il y a
des gens qui sont arrivés par le hip-hop
et d'autres qui n'ont jamais connu le
mouvement électro à ses débuts et quand
on les voit danser on sait que cette
génération elle n'aura rien envie à
cette prédécesseur franchement si
j'avais arrêté à 14 ans comme disait tu
fais la tectonique et bah j'aurais pas
fait me tourner mondiale avec Christine
and the Queens j'aurais pas fait plein
de campagne depuis que je n'aurais pas
créé de compagnie j'aurais enfin la vie
alors était un peu naze quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà si cette vidéo t'a plu tu peux
lâcher un petit like et t'abonner à la
chaîne Youtube de brut aussi si tu as
quelques idées de sujets n'hésite pas à
les mettre en commentaire j'irai les
creuser salut
[Musique]